retour en france une association anti
pesticides a été condamné à verser 125
1000 euros à la filière viticole de
bordeaux selon le tribunal de libourne
les propos tenus par la porte parole
sont des nids gant à l'encontre du
principal syndicat des vins de bordeaux
le cbb et plusieurs domaines viticoles
de la région valérie murat avait dénoncé
cela site la malhonnêteté intellectuelle
du label haute valeur environnementale
selon elle les producteurs de vins
utilisent des pesticides dangereux pour
la santé
il a fait appel de cette décision et
dénonce une volonté de faire taire ceux
qui critiquent les pratiques des
viticulteurs
elle répond à renault parquet si j'en
suis arrivé là c'est parce que mon père
est décédé en 2012 d'un cancer du poumon
qui a été reconnue maladie
professionnelle par la msa la sécu des
paysans bien que mon père et toute sa
carrière respecter les règles d'usagé
les conditions d usage de précaution de
pesticides etc un pesticide qui
s'appelle l'art scénique du sodium qui
l'a empoisonné qui a entraîné sa mort
c'est pour ça que j'en suis arrivé là et
que je milite sur ce sujet depuis
bientôt dix ans maintenant il y à des
substances actives parmi les plus
dangereux sur le marché qui sont les cmr
cancérogènes mutagènes reprotoxiques qui
sont les perturbateurs endocriniens on
connaît aujourd'hui
il y à de nombreuses études qui montrent
la dangerosité sur l'exposition aux
perturbateurs endocriniens pour les
enfants et qui explique bien et qui
démontre bien également que ce n'est pas
la dose qui fait le poison et que une
dose infime de perturbateurs
endocriniens avec un effet cocktail avec
d'autres substances actives peut avoir
des effets ravageurs sur la santé des
enfants
donc c'est ça que j'ai
et montrer en fait c'est simplement que
pour produire ces vins qui sont
labellisés achevé eux il y as d
utilisation de pesticides de synthèse
parmi les plus dangereux et c'est ça que
le seuil bébé et consorts considère
comme un dénigrement